Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live.
Before we get started, just wanna take ten
seconds to say thank you to my employer
Equinix Metal. Equinix Metal is a bare metal
cloud that you can try it for free.
Today, I am giving you Rawkode live as
a coupon code you can apply when you
register Equinix Medal, gives you $50 in credits.
That $50 allows you to spin up our
smallest instance for c three small for around
a hundred hours give or take depending on
what you do with it or you can
splurge that all really quickly and go over
into extra larges with a whopping 384
gig of ram.
If you are not watching live or even
if you are watching live and you want
to chat and ask questions, we do have
a discord but we do encourage comments on
the YouTube comment section too and please remember
to subscribe and thumb up this video. That
would be very much appreciated.
Today, I am gonna take a look at
Pulumi and I have the pleasure of being
joined by two engineers from Pulumi themselves.
Lee Briggs and Paul Stack. Hello. How are
you both doing?
Good. Thanks. You?
Yeah. I am doing very well. It's 5PM
in
very dark Glasgow, but not too bad.
How
about you?
The same. It's five 5PM in very dark
Northern Ireland, and it's miserable as always in
the winter.
Yeah. I'm sorry. Go ahead. No. It's good,
Esther. Yeah.
I'm in Seattle. Yeah. Despite the you you
probably hear that hybrid
northern British and American accent. So
I've been here three years now, and I
swapped
American
miserable weather for sorry. English miserable weather for
American miserable weather. Yeah. I was gonna say
between the three of us here and just
murky, dark, rainy places. Right? Absolutely.
Yeah. 100%.
Alright. Well, could you just both take thirty
seconds each, you know, introduce yourself, see what
you do, and then we'll get we cannot
talk about what we're gonna cover today and
take it from there.
Lee first. Why don't you go? Yeah. So
I'm a I've been at Pulumi, just gone
six months,
and I I guess my new my new
responsibility is
community engineer.
So I'm
kinda building out our content,
external content,
and our workshops
and how to use Pulumi and showing examples.
Before that, I was working with Paul on
the, what we call, the platform teams. That's
our open source CLI
and all the SDKs and and the providers
that we we we currently support.
And as Lee said, I'm Paul Stack. I'm
Stack seventy two on Twitter and pretty much
everywhere on the Internet.
I
predominantly work on the platform side, so I
have a lot to do with the providers
and the CLI, and I'm usually the one
that causes the bugs in in those parts
of the system.
Nice. Awesome.
So why don't we kind of
let's
let's go back to the basics. Right? Why
don't we give a patch about what Pulumi
is? Right? I've got the homepage here. It
says modern infrastructure as code. So what is
what is Pulumi doing? What's the problem in
solving? And what makes it different from other
tools in its its marketplace?
Yeah. I'll take this one. So
if if you're familiar with infrastructures code, you've
probably used some of our competing products.
And they generally either use a configuration language
or a DSL,
like a
wraparound
language that allows you to kind of do
declarative infrastructure as code.
And Pulumi does not take that approach. It
it uses imperative languages
or languages that you may be familiar with
in your software development life cycle.
And it does some magic in our engine
to turn that imperative code into declarative infrastructure.
And so it, you know, it dramatically
helps,
you know, people who are already familiar with
standard software development languages like Go,
the dot net ecosystem,
the Node. Js ecosystem,
and Python
that, you know, it allows you to kind
of really quickly iterate on on that infrastructure
's code. I think we're hopefully gonna see
that today.
Nice. So what what is our goal today?
What are we what are what are we
gonna do?
As as I said on Twitter,
this is a very lofty and an an
ambitious goal.
But the the idea is we're going to
kind of use Pulumi's
brand new
automation API
to show how you can build a,
like, a reusable command line tool to kind
of create infrastructure. And this is a good
example of something you might build if you
are building a platform. So
something that the the the state of DevOps
report came out last week that Puppet does.
And I think it was a very high
number, like something in the 70% of organizations
are trying to build these platforms,
like user friendly ways of provisioning infrastructure.
And one of the great ways is the
one of great things about Pulumi is it
allows you to do this in languages you
feel familiar with, but also make them reusable
and share them between multiple people.
If you think of what, like, Forman used
to be in the VMware and the metal
sorta area, think of, like, being able to
build that type of abstraction, but specifically for
your
infrastructure and your company
and be able to, like, drive that using
Pulumi.
So, Paul, being on the the platform team
at Pulumi then, is this something that user
experiment with yourselves on your own platform as
well?
Yeah. So,
of course, like, this is something that's actually
gonna potentially
be used to replace some of our, like,
infrastructure testing and you know, because we've we've
built up this sophisticated, like, infrastructure testing suite
that runs via
Go test.
And we think that we can probably swap
that out in the future and be able
to use this runtime API to be able
to do it because
it actually gives you access to the the
Pulumi commands that we use and they're wrapped
in a way that makes them a lot
more usable and friendly rather than, like, format
dot sprint f,
Pulumi up, and so on.
Alright. So I if I I mean, my
naive understanding, which is hopefully gonna get better
as we go, but we're gonna build a
command line application
that has some of the Pulumi
API or runtime components baked into it, allowing
me to
modify my state of my Equinix metal hardware
and store that state somewhere and allow me
to make updates to it. Is that naive
guess roughly what we're doing? That's a pretty
app accurate representation.
And the the way
like, I I think I I as I
said on Twitter, like, I have intentionally
done very, very minimal research here, so this
may not be successful.
I think an hour and a half is
pretty optimistic, but we'll see. But the idea
here is to show how,
you know, you would go through this process
if you were going to,
you know, help. But let's say you're in
a development
organization and you wanna provide the capability for
people who aren't familiar with infrastructure's code to
just create testing environments or create,
you know, just even packet in sorry. Equinix
metal instances
to
to provision them nice and easily without having
to write a bunch of, like, a language
they don't understand.
You might go through the process that we're
gonna go through today, basically.
Awesome.
Let me get my screen on here then.
So it's it's great that you said, you
know, nothing is really done in advance and
we're pretty much weighing in this big time
here because at the start of most of
my effect, at the start of every episode,
say, hey, we don't really do anything upfront.
This is transparent. We try and take you
through every step you need to do yourself.
And what I normally do is say here
is what we actually did do in advance
but in this case, it's nothing.
So
I've got an empty go mod file. I've
got an empty read me file and an
empty CLI directory. So we are starting from
as we'd say in Glasgow, hee haw. Hee
haw indeed.
Yeah. So I think the first thing that
we're gonna wanna do here is instead of
kinda like diving straight in and building a
CLI, I think what we probably wanna do
first is build a functioning
Pulumi program
so that we can get all the debug
ability. I mean, you're not exactly gonna build
a CLI right away. So I think the
best thing to do is just create a
new empty directory directory called program or, yeah,
something like that.
I don't think that will work because you've
got things in this directory, so you'll need
an empty directory.
It is Now you can pass dash dash
force.
So, like, what the command that we should
run here will be Pulumi new, and then
we can say packet
dash
whatever the language we want to use, dash
dash force, and Pulumi will scaffold an application.
Now, David, you'll have to forgive us here.
I know we have to rename these templates
to Equinix,
but we'll get to that when we rename
the the provider for you. Don't worry. Our
our team is still doing that ourselves now,
and we've we've been Equinix medal for about
a month. So it's it's not an easy
process, but we're getting there.
So let's just call this new thing. I'm
not fussed about the project name. Yeah. Not
at all. DevStack.
Yeah.
Make it very secure.
Password a b c? Yep.
One two three.
Bang. It's usually mine
for demo. It looks like you're storing your
state in a bucket. Is that right?
Oh, shit.
No. It looks like Probably need to log
in. Probably need to log in.
Let's do it. There we go. We don't
wanna use my production bucket, manual bucket for
that. So
Yes. And all I need to do fine.
It's fine. Let's just pop this open. So
I'll
just rename that stack because I'm pretty sure
I probably already got a dev one and
we'll call this live. I won't have a
live stack, so we should be okay from
there. Encryption still won't need to change, will
it? That should be alright? Should be fine.
Okay. So we have an empty
Pulumi project
and go.
Yes.
You just want me
so you said what we're gonna do is,
you know, write this as if it is
provisional and infrastructures code web Pulumi, and then
we're gonna try and see a lot. So
should I just spend this up a fresh
device with some basic user base? Yeah. I
think the best thing to do is spin
spin up a fresh device. So you'll have
to obviously do your
if you wanna create a new project or
a new organization.
I I generally just
when I'm interfacing with back end, I do
a lookup project.
Oh, I normally just pass it in as
config. I'll just do that because it's what
I'm familiar with. Yeah. Just go down the
path that you're familiar with. And then
the the once the project's done, then just
just new device, I think, is probably a
good start.
This is great because now I get to
just do Pulumi how I do Pulumi, and
then you can fix all my broken bad
habits as well while we're here.
Or the alternative is that Lee and I
actually learned from how we're leader.
Alright. So normally, I would say project ID.
It's
there. Pulumi stack in I guess because I
broke that.
Give it my
Alright. Then we set my project ID in
a config.
I should update our Pulumi live file which
I'm happy with. Nice. Okay. So from here,
what I would normally do, and I normally
do this in typescript, so this will be
fun for me. But packet
dot config.
That's fine. And TypeScript, that would be Pulumi
oh, yeah. Pulumi dot config. Wrong object.
You need to assign it to a variable.
So Yeah. So the Go SDK is a
wee bit more
verbose than than the TypeScript
examples.
Alright. How'd I get the config in Go?
I yeah. Expecting me to know this stuff
off the top of my head. You
let me find this example right here.
I'll go ahead with the device. So we
should actually be able to just new up
so config dot new, pass in a context
and an empty string, and that gives you
access to everything that's inside what's going on
in here. And then you're able to pull
everything out of context of the the config
package.
So
I didn't see a config package.
Oh, you it's it's in a separate import
it. It's in a separate, so it'll be
yeah. Of
course. It's in go. So it you need
to import Pulumi slash config.
There we go.
There we go. So now you should have
con config dot new.
There we go. Right. Pass it in context
and an empty string so you actually access
the the top level namespace. There we go.
Now you can actually pull the config variables
out. And is this the same API, which
I imagine it is? Yep. Yep. The require
project
ID, which is Maybe capital r just because
it's Go.
And it'll probably return an error. Yep.
Oh, no. No. It doesn't require. It doesn't.
I apologize. It doesn't either. Alright. Nice. Okay.
So that's good.
Now I can create a device. We'll save
device, and I'm gonna assume this will give
me an error. That definitely just give you
an error. Yeah.
New device.
Yeah. I see. We're clicking there. Alright. Context.
Name. So we'll call this
what are we gonna avoid this? Does it
matter? Rawkode live. No. I think you could
just give it's just it's just any any
kind of yeah.
And then it will take a struct
A pointer to packet.deviceorgs.
There we go.
Alright. Let's see. Facilities.
A m six.
Is there any specific reason why you choose
AM six or is that just the one
that's closest to you?
Amsterdam's closest to me. That's all. Okay.
Plan, let's go C3MediumX86.
What else do I need? My project ID,
which we got here.
So we probably need to stop here because
the
the Go SDK
is got custom types.
So you'll see the facilities.
It's probably telling you that it doesn't take
a type of array. It takes a Pulumi
dot string array.
And then, yeah, and then you can do
a normal Pulumi dot string. If you're familiar
with the, AWS SDK, this is kind of
a similar kind of pattern.
There we go.
And then that's Just messing something. Right? That's
all I was complaining about. So the Well,
you need to wrap the strings in Pulumi
dot string as well.
So your plan will be a Pulumi dot
string. There we go.
Ah, you can tell I don't use this
API much.
You get used to it. I I kinda
like it. The the the strong typing is
really, really helpful.
I think project ID oh, no. It's the
you need a capital d there.
There we go.
What am I missing?
Oh, it's just not used. Okay. So that's
enough.
And then we need to pass that that
device as a as a pointer. Yeah. There
we go. There we go.
Okay. Let's just clean this up.
So we don't need to have this and
then okay. Let's keep that exports on how
to do that. Otherwise, I'll be looking out
too. So
this is go. So if we need to
do if
error
no.
Oh, no. Here we go. That's a Scottish
Yeah.
And then you just need to return the
error.
So this Pulumi. Run just take just returns
an error.
So you should be able to return the
error there. Yeah.
Alright. There we go. And if we export
the device dot access
public
IP four,
we have a device. Right? Yeah. That should
work. Yeah. Absolutely.
You know what? I mean, haven't used the
Go API
SDK, whatever we call that much. But
it's got some nice qualities to it. I
mean, I'm familiar with Go. I just need
to learn these little
Pulumi We might be we might be missing
a couple extra
details. So we haven't passed in an operating
system.
Oh, I would expect the tape system to
monitor me for that, actually.
I think that's done. We have this new
enum stuff coming, which we should help with
this, but, I think that will probably happen
at
It's done at runtime. At runtime. Yeah.
Yeah. And then we also have to pass
in a billing cycle. Yeah.
Okay. Are there types for that out of
curiosity? Let's see. There are not currently as
of today, but very soon, there's work that's
actually undergoing at the minute that'll allow you
to do that. Oh, nice.
Alright. So hourly
do we wanna just pass in some user
data as well? Yeah. Last thing yeah. Go
on. Go I I would I would my
intent is to get very ambitious and spin
up a Kubernetes cluster. So
what I would do is declare a new
just have a new string that that defines
the user data above this.
And then,
and I would make it a string literal
so that you can do multilines.
But, yeah, like, you can just pass in
Pulumi dot string. Yeah.
Okay.
Session And then I think you need one
more thing according to the packet API, which
is host name.
I think it'll I think it auto generates.
It should be based on the name that
I provided, but we'll do that too.
Let's not test these things just now. Yeah.
So we can leave the user data empty
for now, and then we'll
install Docker on Ubuntu
shortly, I think. Well, let's just make sure
we don't break anything, I guess.
So Just make it a empty yeah.
In bash. Yeah. Empty shebang. Yeah. It's perfect.
I always like to be able to test
it without the export as well. So we'll
we'll just run NGINX.
Interactive
dash. Yes. Okay. So that should give us
once we run this Pulumi program, we'll get
an IP address as the export. We should
be able to hit that in the web
browser. Job done.
Here's the moment of truth.
Alright. So Pulumi API token. Let me get
that sorted first. So Pulumi config set secret
packet API key.
Let me grab that over here.
It's a packet API key or packet auth
token. I can never remember. I need to
look that up. Packet auth token, I believe.
Yeah. Packet auth token. Good. Okay.
Off token.
So an interesting question for you here, David.
Any specific reason why you're using
setting that specifically to your config file rather
than just letting Pulumi pick up your environment
variables?
I don't set environment variables.
Okay. And it needs to be packet colon
off token.
Oh, yeah. I was just gonna come in
and modify it here. Is that okay? Oh,
it's fine. Yeah. Yeah. It's perfect. Oh, because
it's secure, that should be yeah. It should
be alright, I think.
Let's see. Well, let's test it. Yeah. Let's
give it a try. Why not?
Yeah. I I generally don't use the environment
variables in generalistic and
plus it's encrypted so it's safe. Right?
Well, it is. So, like, it's it's actually
using
our secret agent built in by default. So
you can see every time you run Pulumi
up, it's actually gonna ask you for the
passphrase to make sure you have access to
to run Pulumi up. So it's
safe.
Safer, should I say. I'm just used to
using m chain and storing it all in
my key chain. So
I don't know that. So there's something I'm
gonna have to learn from you at some
point. Yeah.
Yeah. I have changed. Pretty cool.
So what you'll notice now this is taking
a second,
and it's because it's building a Go binary.
So it's it's basically doing a Go build
behind In fact, you can probably look at
top and have a look and oh, it's
too late. But you could've looked and seen
it actually doing the compilation.
Alright. So we're gonna say yes to create
a new stack and yes to create a
new device.
It's gonna go away into its thing. I
guess what I can do right now is
move this tab over here too.
Oh.
Unrecognized user data format.
Is that because I put a new line
in, isn't it? I knew that was ambitious.
Yeah.
That that's our API. It's very specific about
that first line and I just went I
when I typed it, was like, I wonder
if that'll work and I should have just
realized that was silly. Anyway, we don't work
now.
And what I will do is we have
a browser here and I've got my console.
That stuff we can ignore.
Let's hit yes.
So we should actually see a device actually
being created by.
There we go. There we go. Beautiful.
Easy.
Alright.
Don't get too confident yet. That's what I
should tell myself.
So that says creating here.
We can see this here.
Here's a question and something I've noticed is
I used to love me quite a lot
now and I always see this message trying
to leak through to me and never quite
see it.
How do I how do I get that
out?
Think this is my font is so big.
It should it should dump it after the
update is finished.
Okay.
So you should see that in the diagnostic
output. Yeah. Yeah. That's that's a debug
statement that's actually leaked through from the the
upstream provider that we use to build our
SDK from.
Alright. Okay.
So of course, we pick up the entire
scheme of the SDK and are able to
to use that, so it picks up the
debug statements as well.
Nice. Okay. At least I I understand why
it's there now, and I'll look for that
in the output afterwards. So so this is
gonna take we're using up into 20, so
probably less than ninety seconds.
So why don't we talk about what's next
then while that's spinning up?
So it depends how it depends how ambitious
we wanna get here.
So my
my intent was to show how you could
bootstrap a Kubernetes cluster with
RKE.
We could go down that path and create
three masters and then actually bootstrap the cluster
from this Pulumi program,
or we can go into building the CLI
right away.
And it's your it's your livestream, David, so
I'll let you let you decide on the
path you wanna go down.
Right. No pressure then. So
That feels like an art an old an
old style RPG where you choose your next
move. It's basically yeah. It's one of those
books that choose your own adventure books. Exactly.
So let me understand what's involved in the
r key r key e bit. Right? That
that's really just wrapping our device r x
m provisioning and a loop for one to
end times and updating our user data to
be installed
RKE. Right? So it will so there's a
there's a
there's a community provider that I built.
So, essentially, the user data will install Docker,
and then we'll do as you said, we'll
loop through all we'll do a loop. So
we'll do three because, obviously, Kubernetes needs three
masters. We'll do three
three devices,
and then we'll pass the output of those
devices to the second provider to bootstrap the
cluster.
And
it it it I mean, I I've I've
used this regularly
outside of Equinix Metal,
so I feel reasonably confident it will work.
But the other thing that we can do
is
we can start implementing the CLI
and do a create instance command just with
what we have here, which I think gives
the same
it gives the same kind of feel to
it, basically.
Yeah. I like that plan. Let's start with
the CLI
version of this, and then we can try
and make it a bit more cooler, bring
it in the other provider and other stuff.
I loved your cap out there. I've used
the outside of Equinix metal. I'm immediately saying,
it fails, it's your fault. Absolutely.
Yeah.
I was actually gonna say it worked on
my machine,
and then I was gonna blame your laptop.
But, yeah, I I think, we like, be
building a CLI, I think, is a pretty
good thing. Look at that. Easy.
Easy. Record time.
So it's important to say here, Lee, like,
we we haven't talked about anything around state
management
because, like, if there's anyone on the stream
who's who's new to state management, then by
default,
we're actually storing the state. Pulumi knows that
that you have built a packet device. And
if we went to or, excuse me, an
Equinox metal device,
and if we actually go to the portal
and we delete that
that device, then Pulumi will actually try you
know, if we refresh it, Pulumi will actually
try and recreate it. So, you know, there
there is state involved in the in the
infrastructure management tier, and I know that there
are some people who are not hugely
happy that state is involved and state is
kept because they believe that, you know, you
should be able to query against the specific
client or the specific metal provider. But there
is actually some state that's involved here.
Yeah.
So I ran a Pulumi up there, and
you can see nothing is nothing is changed.
There's nothing it wants to do there. So,
yeah, that's probably just to know for sure.
So I think you created a CLI directory
before.
Let's let's go ahead and
start bootstrapping a CLI, I think. I think
I just realized I'm using the the header
that doesn't give you access to type in.
Yeah. I was I was feeling a bit
shut out by this whole whole affair to
be honest. Let me close that other one.
That was my mistake.
I get tested not live share one. Okay.
So now you're you're back in the game.
Alright.
So what's the what's the step one to
make this a CLI then?
Inside your CLI directory directory,
I think you already added a go mod,
I believe. Yep.
So I think I I like to lay
out so I'm gonna use Cobra and Viper
to do this, and I like to lay
out these things in a specific way. If
you have if you've used it and you
like to lay it out in a specific
way, then go ahead.
But it's it's totally your call.
So No. Let let's let's learn your way.
Let's do it. So inside the CLI directory,
I would make a CMD
form directory.
And then in here is usually the name
of the CLI as a folder.
So
if we call it something hypothetical
like, we call it CLI right now. Maybe
we'll call it metal CTL,
which will mean you'll have to update the
Go module
path in a few minutes to
and then in here,
you have a main dot Go, which kinda
bootstraps your
your actual
COBRA
application.
So this is a package main.
And then you'll need to import COBRA,
which is
github.comspf13COBRA.
Yep.
And then you need a
configure CLI function, I believe, first.
I think CLI needs to I think it
has specific specific APIs. It needs to be
c and then capitals
capital l, capital I. I guess You wanna
take over the typing and get I could
just do that. It'll be easier. Yeah. I
thought we I thought we were doing this
together. I know it's just a
and then this returns
a here now.
Cobra dot command,
I think.
It isn't auto completing, I don't think. Because
we haven't
We haven't actually installed the Go mod. Yeah.
I'll run a Go mod download just now.
But if we try and see if that
Versus code is going to do, it's really
annoying thing when it tries to remove unused
imports as well. So
Of course.
And so then here, we're gonna create a
root command,
which again returns a Cobra command. I'm just
referencing a previous layout that I have, basically.
And then long
create things
in
Equinix
metal.
Okay.
And so
at this point, we just need to actually
return
a root command,
and that should be pretty
much it for the configure CLI command.
And then I think let me
root command
configure CLI.
I believe that GoMod needs to go at
the top level, David, not inside the
oh, no. No. I take that back. I
apologize. It's it's already at the at the
top level of the CLI directory.
Yeah. I think what if you save this
and just do a first build together to
pull that dependency down, and then we should
get our all complete, hopefully.
So for those not familiar to COBRA, Lee,
why would you use COBRA over something else
in Go?
I really like COBRA because it
allows you to build CLIs that kind of
follow,
like, a 12 factor app approach. So, like,
you can use do things like
have configuration files and bind things to environment
variables. Like, it might be overkill for a
lot of stuff
if you just want flags, basically.
But I I really like the actual
the ability to kind of have a nicely
laid out,
like, CLI structure that's kinda familiar. It's what
the cube the cube CTL
CLI uses.
So, you know, I I I just prefer
it quite honestly. There's there's other things that
I've used,
but this is this is familiar to me.
You probably wanna build that now, and it
should just give you a
standard
metal.
And
then you wanna see if we can run
it. It should just give you
and then run help.
Dash dash help. Dash does help. Yeah. Dash
dash help. Yeah.
Not quite.
I must have missed something here.
Oh, I don't think I have an init
function. That's why. That's probably not gonna help.
I'm
very new to this.
Actually, I don't think we can probably just
leave this empty now that I think about
it.
Alright. Let's try again.
Oh, I'm in the wrong directory.
Oh,
typo.
Oh, no. I need to save. There we
go. Try again.
There we go.
So now we actually have a
the the very much the beginning boilerplate of
a CLI. Right?
And so if we wanna actually run our
create
create device
thing inside the CLI, we could create a
directory underneath
underneath this this kind of parent directory. I
have access to create directories, so I'm gonna
let you do this.
So under metal CLI,
let's create a directory called
create.
And then under that, we'll go with device.
Directory or fail?
Another directory. So then we're gonna have, like,
nest and this it like, the the reason
that I kind of have this layout is
it allows you to create,
like like, create a more reusable CLI. So
then each one of those will have a
CLI dot go in them.
Alright.
Is it my turn again? I believe it
is. So
what we're gonna do here is create
a
standard command.
So, again, it's very similar to the pattern
we've already have.
Command
equals
dot
command.
Use is create
short
I think I need to change the format
of the show. It's much more fun watching
other people type.
And you can always blame them if it
goes wrong. Yeah. Absolutely. And
so this is the most important thing. This
runny function is basically gonna make a decision
about
what happens when you run this command.
And so that takes a
COBRA dot command
and then a bunch of arguments
as a string,
and it returns
an error.
And then here is where we're gonna put
our logic. And this is actually going to
really only have,
like, the the commands below it in it
because these these create
this create
thing itself doesn't actually do anything. It just
we just have sub commands in here. So
what we'll do is do command dot add
command,
and it'll be
create
instance
dot
command.
So then what we'll need to do here
is import
the directory
below it.
I don't actually know the full path of
the import path, but it'll be
do you wanna fill that out, David? Like,
the actual
it's from the main yeah. That. Yeah.
I'm in the wrong bit. And
then it's gonna be the subpackage. So,
create.
Metal c l first? Or Metal c t
l. Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. Create.
There?
Device.
And then instance.
Oh, it's yeah. It device. Yeah. Yeah. It
is device. Yeah. Good good point. So let
me change that.
Okay.
Just so I understand then. This means that
what we're doing here
is we're
is this supposed to be command and
full?
Or is that should this be this variable
here that we're adding it to? CMD?
It should be CMD?
Yes. It should be CMD. You're absolutely right.
Okay. So we're the context is passing a
root command and then we can add subcommands
to it and we're adding
our own.
Yes. Trying to I'm trying to remember the
path that I've gone through here. Yes. And
then we also need to actually, you know
what? I'm I'm I'm completely wrong here. We
don't actually need any of this. This
is this is why you do
this is why you do
because we don't need a runny for these
create commands at all because this isn't gonna
do anything.
It's just a registration with the top level
binary.
Right.
So then this goes here.
That goes
there.
So all we're doing it would this is
just a
we're just importing that. So package and running
it in the context of this.
And so then if we open the device
dot command, this is where all of our
logic will go.
So
this gives you the ability in the CLI
to be able to say mental CTL create
and then device as a sub command of
create.
Okay.
I promise you it'll work.
But to me
this is device. This file. Right? This is
the device slash c l I dot go,
and we're referencing ourselves.
Oh, I thought I was in the create
dot go. That's probably where we're that's probably
where the confusion is. That's where the confusion
is coming from. So all of this needs
to go into the create doc. So in
the create
directory, there needs to also be a cli.go.
For those people watching for those people watching,
I can actually see the file name. I
can only actually see where we are. So
all this needs to go into there.
Okay.
And the package needs to be create
at the top there.
Alright. Okay. So we come into device now.
This is package device.
Yeah. And then we probably do have a
run e here then. Right? Yes. That's right.
Yeah. Okay.
But let's before we actually start adding all
Pulumi logic in there, let's,
like, actually make sure this all builds.
So we need to change that. Yeah. We
need to change that to be device. This
needs to be like a a
proper scaffold of a COBRA command.
Yeah.
I think it still needs to runny. So
how do we just do a a function
or expression that says hello, world? What what
was the parameter for runny again? Func.
Which takes a command a c m d,
which is a pointer
to cobra dot command
and args,
which is an array of string.
Args.
And it returns an error.
It needs to be the other way around.
An array of string, not string array.
Yeah.
The typescript come they can Yeah.
Hello. Yeah. So that should just be hello
world. Yeah. Device create.
Nice.
Alright. Let's change the use to be from
create because we're inside the package of device.
Let's change the use to be device.
Yeah.
Yep.
Hey. Why are you mourning about Go? Missing
thing.
I don't have the import. I used to
do that automatically. Come on, Go.
Versus code, I guess.
Unused command. How do we do we just
not assign it? No. No. You have to
return it, I think. Return it. Yep. And
it needs to be down there.
There we go. That's what I'm thinking. Right.
Okay.
So let's go build.
I think we're gonna have an error one
level up.
Not a dire yeah. I think you need
to remove the CLI because that's not actually
that's just the directory. It's not in the
go path.
It could be wrong.
Oh, we need to return a command here
as well.
It's not I believe. Either.
Versus code let me down big time today.
So you're you're you're trying to take Lee
and I out of our comfort zone. We're
jet Yeah. My I'm missing my IntelliJ right
now. Big time.
Alright. Device create. So there's a problem with
this import here. So metal CTL
create
like It's because device
if you go back to command device yeah.
You've you've named it
create or you've named it device as the
as the actual package itself. So go inside,
yep, the CLI for device,
And you'll see in here, you've renamed it
device, and it doesn't it needs to be
command.
So line nine, as you look at it
now, it needs to be func command.
Right. Yeah. There we go.
And I think it's because this is in
the subdirectory CMD.
So if you go back to
import on
device CMD.
Right. Got it. Yeah. Okay.
Three
professional software engineers here having a great time.
Right. It's much harder without Stack Overflow.
So then you should have
Device.
Oh, we had need to import device into
the root
into the root command as well.
Of course. So so here, we're gonna need
to
add it. It's in the it will be
in the in it, I think, in the
configure CLI. Yeah.
So in here, you just need above return
root command.
Line 14 as you look at it now.
Yeah. So then do root command
Dot add command. Dot add command
device
dot command.
Sorry. Create dot command.
Yeah. Create.
Not device.
No. Create dot command,
not device dot command. There we go.
And now they are all complete, and then
all imports is working. Yeah.
So there we go. Now so now, hopefully,
you can see there we have
created this directory structure.
Not use create command type font COBRA as
co
argument to add command.
Interesting.
Can I take a look? Calling it. Right?
Oh, no. I need to call it. There
we go. There we go.
Okay.
Interesting.
What have I got wrong?
Oh, we're all in this together, David.
Do we have to add no. We add
create, which references device.
Yeah.
And their main reference is create.
Yeah. That looks good.
See, I'm usually copying and pasting this stuff.
So like I've added well, I had it
working once
and it was good enough.
Let me
Okay.
That looks good too.
That's a binary what we're doing.
Let me pull up the corporate app.
I'm sure it's something really simple.
Yeah. It's probably something very, very simple.
So it looks like the edit the edit
function should have the root add command.
Ah, yeah. You're probably right, actually.
Well, so this the way that this is
laid out is a little different to the
way that I usually lay them out. If
you wanna open
yeah. That could work.
What are you complaining about, Annette?
Back to
Let's just try and compare it. Maybe it
should be as good.
Nope. Not be as good. It's always me.
Never be as good.
Because I'm just not paying any attention. There
we go. Alright. So
we still probably wanna return the root command
here. Right? Yeah.
Which keeps that happy. This is now complaining.
The root command is undeclared,
and that's because here it is the same.
It needs to be that, I believe.
Nope. Have you got it? Oh, you're doing
it. Alright. Okay. No. I thought I thought
that was the answer, but I was, unfortunately,
wrong.
Oh, yeah. Okay. So they create the root
command in the global scope by the way
of bit, But whereas we're doing it in
configure CLI.
I don't let's just take Yeah. And it
actually fires before main, so that's trouble.
Yeah. I don't think we need that bit.
Right?
So we need to declare it as a
VAR.
It just needs to be equals,
not colon equals. The VAR. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
And this is root command.
There we go. It's not complaining.
Yeah. That's better.
Well, does the create command. If you do
metal CTL create, it might just not be
showing in the help.
Yeah. And then the the device, if you
do create device.
It's not registering.
It's not registering the commands, but I
don't understand.
It's very hard to do this when you,
like, have a established pattern
that you follow.
Hold on.
I am a semi competent programmer. I can
work with it. So
look at this example.
Alright. We define our recommend,
add commands, which we're doing.
I mean, they don't even have a main.
Oh, they just call command execute here. Okay.
And the command is their module,
which exposes
an execute.
We've got root command equals
root command execute.
Looks good. So I'm assuming that it's not
being called, I'm gonna call
in it.
We can pay all that.
And that complains
because Yeah. And and it's not a function.
Yeah. I'm just gonna do that. Let's
let's just do that.
And then that's complaining because
The import is gone.
Alright. Okay. That is back now.
Yep.
Build.
Help.
Why does it hit me?
I wouldn't mind, but I have a working
version right in front of me as well.
So
Do you wanna swap over?
Do you think we'll spend another five minutes
and see if we can fix this? Yeah.
I think we I think I think everybody
wants to see us fix this.
And if you are watching and you're pointing
something out and you're on your monitor, feel
free to put it in the comments because,
you know,
that would be nice.
Okay. So we define a root command and
we add our subcommand here. Now we know
this is working because we're getting create things
in Equinix Mail thing. Right? It it does
see that. Yep.
Now the ads command
for create,
which is this one here,
has a func command,
returns itself, and adds a sub command here.
And then the sub command does the exact
same.
Only this one has a run expression, which
should work. So
I mean, that looks pretty faint.
I'm looking at these examples and I'm like,
yeah, it's it's good.
Wonder if it's am am I building it
wrong? Let's try go build.
So I usually just do go run. If
you do go run
CMD
metal CTL may not go.
Okay.
So then you do create.
Create device.
So it's just my Google build of everything
for some weird reason.
Who knows? Right. Anyway, we'll we'll move on.
Okay. So
now that we have this capability to kind
of create
things from within the CLI,
we can put
a Pulumi program in our create device,
like run e. So if we go back
to the editor
inside our run e
And this isn't like, the what we were
doing so far isn't even the hard part.
So
we were just building a very, very simple
very, very simple CLI.
But we can import
the Pulumi automation API as a go package
and actually execute it from within this function.
And
I believe
that
it is under it's
Pulumi,
github.comPulumi/Pulumi,
and then it's SDK
v two
go
x
for for
experimental
and then forward slash auto.
So this gives a bunch of Go
for it, Lee. Sorry. This is like, there's
a bunch of packages in here as well.
But, essentially, this is a bunch of packages
that kind of give you
everything that is available in the Pulumi open,
the Pulumi destroy,
like, commands,
essentially.
So
I think the best thing to do,
first of all, is to
create
a
there's a bunch of ways that you can
create the stacks that we were doing inside
the,
you know, with the previous thing. You can
either reference a git URL or you can
actually have the code in line inside your
inside your function. So
I think the best thing to do here
is to create a
stack first.
So we'll need to remove the format print
line.
New variable stack name. And I guess I
could do this if you really want me
to.
Let me see if I can take over.
Stack
name
equals
auto
dot fully
qualified.
So Pulumi Pulumi SDK isn't actually included in
the go model here, so you'll not get
auto complete yet.
Yeah. We need to do it. Just bear
minimal and save it, and then we'll get
it complete.
And
you aren't using the Pulumi SaaS back end,
so we can just probably call this
let's just call it foo for the time
being, you know, because everybody loves
everybody loves a good variable
in here. And I think, Paul, you implemented
this, right, for the local back ends? So
it doesn't need to be
slash namespace or anything like that. Right? No.
No. It shouldn't be. Okay. Excellent.
And then
we wanna to get all complete?
Yes. Let's do it. Go ahead. Yeah. So
just you'll have to just return null.
Yeah.
Actually, it oh, yeah. Return null and then
yeah. There you go.
And then
You can't declare to an underscore. Just remove
the colon. There we go. There we go.
Okay. So let's
let's get the go mod going.
There we go. All the Pulumi goodness coming.
And we can probably just ignore that, and
I'll put your stack in back.
Thank you.
And we should have auto complete.
Exactly.
And then we can create a Pulumi stack,
and it comes from
auto.op.
It didn't seem to get the autocomplete.
It's still downloading.
The view
oh.
Yeah. If I think if you just finish
that, that code.
Opposite.
I can probably figure it out.
So this takes a context. It takes the
stack name we just declared,
and then it takes a
project name. I was just gonna call this
Rawkode
Live
and then a program.
So in here,
this final
I don't actually know how to
do the peak in here. But this this
final thing in here where I'm specifying nil
is where we're actually going to specify a
stack.
If I didn't want clean code, I could
actually just literally inline
my Pulumi stack in here.
But what we probably wanna do
instead
is
do
if error is not equal now, return error.
Make sure we're doing alright.
And then equals
Pulumi.
Lee,
let's remove this, fully qualified stack name. We
should just declare it as foo rather than
anything else. So stack name equals foo.
Probably a good idea. Agreed.
Error equals
so now we create a stat. We also
need to create create what we call a
workspace,
and this is essentially like a a directory
that's gonna
hold all of our config.
So we workspace.
And then in that workspace,
we can do a bunch of plug in
installs, which we don't actually need to do
because you have them already locally. So then
we use workspace
dot set program,
and then
insert
program
here.
In this in this set program, it basically
takes just a standard function. So let's create
func
new
device.
And I'm gonna ask for your help here,
David. So the
Pulumi
program that we did before will need to
copy a bunch of that stuff from there
into this new device function,
essentially.
And I like to namespace these into packages,
but we can we can probably just do
that in line for the time being.
Okay.
Let me find where that
is.
So do you want the alright. Okay. Got
it. So
All of this, yeah, all of this goes
into that particular
thing. Yeah.
And then we should be able to do
new device
in here.
What's that
yelling at me for?
That's an extra. Yeah.
Alright. So it's not done our auto imports.
So let's
try and get a bit of help. Go
mod download.
Oh, c ah, c d c l I.
Go mod
download.
Okay. And then pop back over here.
We probably also need to import
Well, that's the wrong config.
And we also need the v three
SDK of packet, Pulumi packet.
It's pulled in.
Yeah. That's probably the best thing.
Online right below. There we go. Yep.
Let's save that.
Almost happy. So new Yeah. There's no context
being passed down into that file. Yeah. So
we need a Pulumi.
Context being passed into here,
which is Pulumi's
custom
or specified type.
Return
The function doesn't return anything.
Yeah. No? K.
Think that As in it needs to return
an error is what I mean. The signature
needs to return an error. Yeah. Alright.
It's happy. Unbelievable.
Oh, no. It's almost Oh, wait. No. It
isn't. Because you have to pass in context.
Yeah. Okay.
And that's not the correct context unfortunately because
we've just newed up a context dot background
and we actually specified a Pulumi dot context.
Okay.
So does that mean do we just initiate
a new Pulumi context?
Pulumi doc. I see a con a new
context API.
I think actually what might be easy here
is if we do
var
create
device
func
equal or create an anonymous function here, c
d x
Pulumi
dot context,
and then return
an error,
and then get rid of
this.
And then we can do
that.
I think
that should do it.
It's
not yelling at us.
So let's
let's go for it. Go run. What's the
worst that can happen?
A few more packages.
We could bring the whole of, Equinix meltdown,
I guess, in a in a really bad
situation.
Jesus, don't joke.
Pulumi stack dot workspace.
Okay.
So now it's morning about our imports.
We've not got Pulumi.
Pulumi's here.
Can you show me your imports again?
Yep.
I think the
can I see the error again?
Yes. Let's see.
So
Pulumi stack dot workspace
undefined.
Oh, wait. Is that workspace supposed to have
a capital s?
Probably need to declare a new workspace.
I'm not getting any out complete,
of course, because it's morning about
I mean, that's the
context isn't resolving.
There's multiple Pulumi resolves.
This is a very weird error.
Yeah. Looks
Has it has it pulled an old version
of the Pulumi SDK that doesn't have this
package in it? Let's check a
go mod.
So we're pulling
No. We're pulling two thirteen too, which is
correct. That's fine. Yeah.
I believe the issue is there's no function
called workspace.
It needs a new workspace. Right?
I don't think so. No. I'm looking at
my previous attempt at this, and it seems
to be
Well, I'm
gonna assume because the auto complete is not
working.
Something
is not right with the imports.
So what does it think a Pulumi stack
is?
It has no idea.
Invalid type. Right? So whatever this upsert stack
and lane, which it can't resolve either, and
it's
got auto going to SDK b two go
I I think this is because we removed
the fully qualified stack name, which is a
specific type,
and it just isn't taking a string. Yeah.
I think that's what it is. Okay. So
let's go try and go back to that
first and see if that gives us a
Pulumi stack. Still an invalid type, unfortunately.
And I can't get any tooltip on this
upstart stack and lane function
or on that. Yeah. So what's wrong with
the auto import?
Nothing.
Should it be Pulumi x auto?
I don't think so.
Certainly not looking at my
my working version of something similar to this.
Yeah. I am literally just copy and paste
it from so unless it's changed unless it's
changed
recently, which I doubt.
Okay. So auto knows is that.
And then it just
okay. So maybe this is just Versus code.
Right? And it's a little bit confused.
So let's assume that bringing the stack name
back and maybe fixed it, and then let's
run the compile again.
That's gonna give us a different error. Okay.
So now set program is undefined, but that's
at least progress. So Yes.
So Oh, that's because we that Pulumi stack
dot
workspace isn't
What was that supposed to be again?
It should be
set
let me look back at my previous example
here.
Should just be dot workspace. So that should
be right with a lowercase s.
Okay. So we did have an uppercase at
least. So maybe that was the problem.
Alright. And okay. So now the fully qualified
stack name one. So this is what I
think Paul was trying to get us away
from, so we should be able to remove.
So the fully qualified stack name is Tate
is expecting a so, yeah, we should be
able to put foo in there
and then remove the stack name.
Okay.
This is one
step at a time.
This is professional software development.
It's working.
Right.
Okay. So the only thing missing from our
example right now is that we have set
up a workspace and set a program, but
we don't actually have an op.
So we
probably need to actually add that because otherwise
nothing's gonna happen.
So let's do
error
equals Pulumi
stack
dot
up
c t x.
And then I can't this takes a,
so we're gonna need takes context,
and it takes,
a progress stream.
Yes. So
so we're gonna need a new import.
And then that will need to be
here.
I'm gonna just copy and paste it so
that we can save
ourselves all the time. And then we'll need
also
OS,
and that should be it. I think that
should be everything.
We just need to check the error response
here.
Oh, yeah.
And then lastly, Lee, we can actually grab
the value of the outputs
of the IP.
So
So let's call that res
or output. Yeah. Res is fine. Res is
better because it's a response.
And then we can say res dot output,
and we can grab
I think we called someone from it's we
actually have to call
into the index of outputs.
So it's an array of outputs.
We
well, you can actually call it directly out
by name, what we call the output further
down in our application.
So square brackets.
Device IP.
And then we can say dot value because
we need to grab the value out of
that. And the value comes out right now
as an interface, so we need to string
on the end.
So we need to cast it to string.
Not dot
and then end string. Yay. There
we go. No no two string. Just string.
Just lowercase string. Oh, yeah. Lowercase.
And we probably wanna print it. Right? So
let's do format a print line.
There we go.
Alright. Let's just ignore the errors from code.
I think it's definitely very confused.
No. We don't want this to cause a
duplicate device, so I'm just gonna modify the
host name here. Yeah.
And we can change that a little bit
to generate a random ID and pass it
in if we need to. I think it's
worth pointing out at this stage. Like, you
know, we're obviously just going through the process
here. But because
because we're building this into a CLI, like,
we can do things like add flags so
we can give it, like, a if we
wanted to, we could have dash dash device
name and then pass that all the way
through the stack. And, like, it gives you
that flexibility to kind of build it all
into your CLI. We're just kind of bootstrapping
it at the moment.
Alright. So we did have a
someone
watching our stream tell us they spotted a
table, which I've fixed. Thank you for that.
M van bus 40 three.
So we're gonna run this now. Right? We're
gonna try it. What's the worst that could
happen?
Imports because VSC is now confused.
Yeah.
Let's see. What do we need? Do we
need streamer opt up?
We have opt up.
Up.
We need to declare streamer rather than set
it. Oh, yeah. Call on equals.
We need the same on line four just
below it. So Pulumi stack up. So we
need to set. There we go. Yes. Because
we added it's because we added those variables.
Right?
I'll stop enabling my relative plain numbers and
confuse you.
It's fine. I have them.
Almost there. So now it's complaining about our
outputs lane.
Oh, actually progress streams is undefined.
Maybe that type wasn't a typo?
No. It definitely was a typo.
Alright. Well, let's fix the lane forty five
first, and then we'll see. So
it doesn't like this.
Well, I think we can probably just comment
that out for the time being and actually
get the thing launched and then figure out
how to export the the values from there.
Alright. There we go. We need streamer, though.
Right? Yeah. Okay.
Undefined opt up progress streams.
Let's just pull up the docs.
Did it pull the import? It's did it
pull It's definitely there. You might need to
re pull the import because you haven't run
GoMod since.
Is that the
Let's just add it to go mod manually
then.
I don't how did it get here? I
copied it in there. Oh,
it's it's included in the package, in the
SDK v two package. It's just that it
it wasn't actually grabbing it.
So we should be better now.
Nope.
We're so close. We've got fifteen minutes. We
can get this first thing created. I believe
in us.
So undefined auto progress streams.
And so it knows that package is there.
S t k v two x auto opt
up.
And then it just falls over.
It's a % there. I'm actually looking at
the package right now.
Can we just do a
yeah.
Is there a typo maybe?
Ah,
we're missing an r. So even though we
got corrected
We got corrected, and we didn't actually correct
it properly. Awesome.
Modern software development, guys.
That's
fine. Yeah. It's because we're yep. Res is
used. That's fine. Just make it under there
we go.
Now we might get one more error here.
Alright. Okay. So
yeah. I'll just underscore. Let's go back to
the input in a minute.
Let's get it working.
Oh, so you'll need to
that's you'll need to change that because it's
no new variable. Yeah.
So annoying. For real. Value isn't a func.
That's why on the output,
it's just a value dot value dot.
So it shouldn't actually be a function here.
That's it.
That looks better.
There we go.
Alright.
So we need to pass in create on
device
as
yep.
And now we should actually have an application
starting to spin up.
Okay.
This is the because that's password protected. No.
Yeah. It's because we we'll have to actually
like,
with we don't get the interactivity that you
usually get
with
yeah. With
Now we can actually see David's password.
Alright. It sees a new password. I don't
need the password from the last code, though.
Right?
Oh, now I'm gonna have to expose the
auth token. Right?
No.
Because right now, there's no API key in
my environment.
Yes. You probably will. Yes. Alright. Hold on.
Let me move this over here, sneaky.
So you can't see it.
And then I'll expose this on my environment.
Export
packet.
I can't remember if it's API gear also,
but I'm gonna do both. So
There is a set config function in there
as well. Like, we could set it in
the actual code.
But
Magically
pull this back.
Command k. Command k. Command k. I know.
I I always run PSE UX before it,
so there's loads of back buffer. That's okay.
It's not a bad idea, actually.
Livestream things.
Alright. So Pulumi
config pass throughs to create a vase. Hopefully,
it picks up my token.
There's still one more error that I think
we have to resolve here. We'll send to
you. Okay.
And error is
An unhandled error occurred. That doesn't sound good,
does it?
It feels like we're close, though. Oh, we
we have. I feel like we're close too.
Yeah.
Alright. So it just seems to be unhappy
with our online source.
Now we did There's function here.
Yeah. To this anonymous
function.
And it does require a project ID, which
doesn't exist right now. Should we hard code
this? Just hard code it. Yeah.
Because we don't have a config.
So And, again, you can do this within
the actual
The API itself? Yeah. You can do it
with Lizard. Lizard is a we probably won't
get time to do it, unfortunately. But there
is a
and then you probably just don't need the
config dot new at all at that point.
That still have to be a Pulumi string,
Yeah. Yep.
Well, you've actually set it as a Pulumi
string. Yeah. It doesn't need to be just
a standard string.
You can move config.
Not used anywhere else.
Alright. Let's see what happens.
I think the other error could be we're
still not using our Pulumi. Context.
Nope. There it is. There we go. There
we go. We have an API up and
running. And and now I see my debug
messages that I've never seen before. Yeah.
So this should be creating if we check
the the web,
it should be creating a new instance.
There we go.
I think well, I think that's
a success. That's quite why we're ahead.
So can we
take a few minutes to just go over
this code, what it's doing, and then
talk about what we no. Because I I
think I really do wanna explore this future
with my own code and my own tools
and stuff like that for Equinix. So if
we can just kinda cover what this is
and what the potential next steps are without
actually going into it, then that would be
really useful.
Yeah. So,
like, when I've done this before, we we've
taken a bunch of shortcuts here, essentially.
But, like, the the key thing really is
this auto to up upsert stack inline source.
And we've hard coded a bunch of values
here, like the project
and the stack name and all that kind
of stuff.
But you can make this all configurable via,
like,
standard COBRA flags and and arguments,
which allows you to kind of make repeatable
deployments.
So a pattern that I think is really
useful is
I always
use the same project name. So let's say
we call this metal CTL
as we have. Like Rawkode live, we could
change that to metal CTL and then have
multiple deployable instances within that same project. And
then, like,
magically generate a stack name for each one
that allows you to then do things like
you can list the existing stacks. You can
destroy the existing stacks.
It it allows you to create this really
repeatable pattern.
But essentially, that auto auto
dot upsert stack inline source allows you to
pass any Pulumi program to it.
And there's other mechanisms as well that you
can do auto dot I can't remember exactly
what it is, but you can grab you
can have your stack in a separate Git
repo
and have them be,
you know, versioned,
you know, separately
is is another pattern that that I think
we've seen used.
But essentially a questionnaire?
Sure. Go ahead. Alright.
So I just wanna make sure I understood
that right because that sounded like a pretty
awesome superpower. So we're using auto up search
stack online source,
but
I
the get thing I thought was really interesting.
So what well, how does that work? How
would what would that mean? So there's two
there's other there's other variants here. Right? So
you can have
remote source, local source, or inline source. So
it depends on where your Pulumi application that
you wanna execute is actually stored. So if
you think of creating your wrappers, storing them
in your GitHub org, then you can actually
reference the wrappers from within that upsert stack
command.
So rather than upsert stack in lands inline
source, there'll be another function where you can
actually pass in the the Git remote. Does
that mean I can pass Multiple Git repositories
all with templates of environments like RKE clusters,
Kubernetes clusters, SaltStack clusters, and I can just
tell
use some sort of COBRA flag and say
here, use this as a Exactly it. Exactly
it. Very, very clear. So it's like a
think of it as like a a central
orchestrator
across
many sort of parts of their your infrastructure
that you have to bring together,
specifically point into different resources
held either in GitHub,
locally, or as an embedded exactly in what
we've done today.
Sweet.
And it's it's also worth pointing out as
well, like,
we've kept all of the
we've used the Pulumi Go SDK and the
Cobra CLI because it makes sense to have
Go and Go. But the if you use
a remote stack
reference, you can write your Pulumi stacks in
whatever you want.
So, you know, if if you if you
want to
provide a super easy to distribute binary,
Go might be a good choice for creating
ECLI.
But then you can write the actual Pulumi
stacks in whatever language you feel comfortable with.
If you've written a bunch of TypeScript, put
them in a remote Git repo, run
metal CTL up, and, you know, you're pretty
much good to go.
So there's a lot of lot of stuff
there. Some of the stuff that we didn't
cover, for example,
in this workspace
thing. So if you go to on line
32,
we've got work state space equals Pulumi stack
dot workspace.
You can also automate the installation of plug
ins as well in the in the user's
environment. So, you know, David, I know you
have the plug ins installed already. But if
you would say distributing this to a
developer on your team or something like that,
you can actually automate for the local environment
the installation of the plugins they need as
well. So
that's all part of the the kind of
API that we provide,
which again, it it, you know, it gives
them the
that kind of, like, self-service
capability
to just, hey. I'd install this thing, and
you can install best practice
stuff really, really easily.
K. That's awesome.
So
let's talk about the state then that's going
on here.
Can this connect to all the same state
back ends that my regular Pulumi commands would
be using?
Yeah. So it it basically
follows the Pulumi login that you have at
the moment.
So the only way that we have to
interact with
Pulumi
is the Pulumi CLI needs to be installed
on your machine.
So, like, a good practice that I've recommended
is, let's say, I'm creating my metal CTL
command.
I would also want to
have, like, a homebrew tap, and I wanna
have a dependency on the Pulumi homebrew installation
as well. And then you have to do
a Pulumi login to get all your stack
stuff. So you did a Pulumi login local
earlier.
Anybody who wants to use your command will
have to do a Pulumi login to whichever
back end that you're using, like the s
three back end. And then after that, it's
pretty much, you know, open season.
I mean,
yeah, I I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna say you're wrong. Right? Everything
you said there is is right, but I've
got an idea in my head since that
this is just a corporate application. Right? There's
no reason I couldn't have another sub command
that could automate the stack log in and
the downloading of the gold binary before I
ever touched those Pulumi SDK component. It's like,
it's really do whatever I want to certainly
do. I mean, you could have a metal
CTL in it that basically like, again, like,
one of the great things I I I
mentioned it earlier, like, the the idea around,
like, platforms.
And ultimately, what we're really trying to build
here is,
you know, user friendly
applications.
Right? And for those three, like a CLI
is super user friendly.
But you you can follow whatever your business
logic needs. So you could do a Pulumi
sorry, a metal CTL in it
that sets your environment up, does your login,
all that kind of stuff,
and then you can use it, you know,
pretty straightforward. Like, it's it's all just you
know, I know this is this term is
thrown around a lot, but it's all just
code at the end of the day. Right?
Like, you you know, if you can write
it, you can do it. And I think
with a lot of the other kinda infrastructure
as code tools that are available, these kind
of work workflows
are either wrapped in thousands of lines of
bash or,
you know, they're they're they're not as as
user friendly, basically.
Oh, yeah. Like, we we actually have one
of our engineers at our current hack day.
He wrapped this up in an electron app
and actually had a very simple UI that
someone was able to launch and spin up
infrastructure.
And all it's doing in the background is
just making the API requests in exactly the
same way as we've done it from the
CLI.
Okay. That's pretty sweet as well. There's just
so much
what is it we call this? The automation
API? The Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I can already think of a
billion things I wanna do with this API
and the workflows I could provide to to
not just end users, but at my own
team. Like, the amount of Yeah. Things we
could automate that were just painful otherwise. We're
very excited about this automation API. Like, I
think when it was launched, it was the
the the blog post was something called, like,
the the next quantum leap
in infrastructure
as code. And and, like, it it really
can be. You know, if you have this
real ability that you can launch anything from
anywhere, I using any type of of system
that that fulfills your environment and and and
how your users want to use it internally,
then that's really pretty cool. You know, you
can allow your designers who are not savvy
with APIs or CLIs
with a very simple UI, they can create
multi cloud
Kubernetes clusters or whatever they need to do.
Yeah. And it's it's you know, we've only
interacted with one provider here as in the
the packet slash metal, you know, Equinix metal
provider. Be one? No. They can only they
can be many. You can have as many
as you like. You know, like like, let
let's say you wanna create a CLI
that provisions your application
for your team and, you know, they need
they you know they need a Cloudflare
URL or something like that.
You know, we've got one resource. We could
do, like, the
BGP stuff all wrapped in here and and
all that kind of stuff.
Yeah. And, of course, this can this can
also be used to
trigger off your dynamic providers. If you've written
specific dynamic providers that you need to use
as part of your flow, you can embed
in the dynamic provider in here as well.
Right. You're
putting too many ideas in my head now.
That's what I just let's
I just pasted on that code that you
sent me, Paul, on on the chat. So
this is the example of using a the
Pulumi examples repository as a provider for those
stack
examples. Right? And then we just say stack
remote source. We tell it the repository and
then those become available as things I can
just been up. Right? Yeah. I understood that.
Right? Yeah. Okay. Cool.
Awesome.
That was
a very exciting. And I can see
so many different possibilities of things that can
be automated there. You know, I think it's
really cool that you mentioned that we can
use multiple providers there. You know, one of
Equinix's secret sauces, if you were, was interconnection
to all the cloud providers. Been able to
spin up
a JKE cluster, an EKS cluster, and one
on Equinix metal and have them connected by
a fiber backbone
is something that I'm now gonna make my
life's work or at least for the next
three
use new automation API. Yeah. And you can
do it all in a you know, you
can do call it super cluster. Exactly. And
yeah. And have a a magical super multi
cloud cluster.
I it's really a super cluster if you
don't have a Raspberry Pi cluster on your
desk? Well, yeah.
Well, maybe I'll try and work that better
as well then.
Alright. Well, we've been a little bit over,
but I think it was worth it. I'm
glad that we we got to them. We
got it working. I'm hoping that other people
now see this as, you know, a good
example and basis and starting point for them
to build their own really cool CLIs with
this. And as you said, not even just
CLIs, hooking up to electron or even web
applications that can call out and execute this
stuff. Very, very powerful. So as
always, I'm super impressed with the Pulumi stuff.
Thank you for doing what you're doing and
keep at it. Thanks thanks for having us.
No. My pleasure. Have an awesome evening, morning,
whatever time it is in Seattle right now.
Paul, you have a great time in London
and I'll speak to you both again soon.
Thank you for joining me. It's a pleasure.
Take care. Thanks. See you later. Bye.